ok ragazzi il primo ricominciare video
volevo farvi di prendere dall'ultima
parte dov'eravamo rimasti
ed è successo questo per farti saltare
la testa non mi toccare chi rinuncia che
bello che sei anche tu botta di culo
assurda ragazzi via subito via madre tua
madre la madre è più bella di te ma
quanto sei bello dopodiché ragazzi ho
continuato il video oggi quindi godetevi
pure questa avventura molto tranquilla
bella tutti ragazzi e poi minuti
avessero video son of a vj e ci siamo
dati sulle soft gioco per bambini vero
armando con un ragazzino rimasti si
lavori massi che c'erano i ragazzi
armando stai fermo è che c'è il pd non
c'è il pisello qualche il fatto che
ancora non sto dove sto
c'è ancora il tizio che cerca la [ __ ]
appello del sia ancora l'hai trovato la
patata stavo scherzando fratello sfigato
scherza tosca giornata riparte ce la
puoi fare
la [ __ ] chi sei piacere ciao sono
famiglie
sì anche qui ad ascoltarmi porca [ __ ]
ragazzi cosa succede
vedo in 3d è scoppiato il 3d a caso va
bene sentite ma guarda che se volete gli
occhiali 3d costano 5 euro si lanciata
che son orto per ragazzi benvenuti sul
layer software un gioco senza senso sono
svenuto perfetto non ho mai e così è
tranquilli
e normale che sia così strano e tutto
questo gioco è fatto di robben non ho
capito ancora due siamo ciao sono fa vj
faccio il dj faccio sempre il dj che
presta e la porta di camera mia quando
porto un 4 a mia madre più o meno alla
stessa roba anche la mia prof mi diceva
di leggere però non mi ha mai lanciato
libri grazie però sta diventando tragico
gia.fi zio non si apre la scala arrivo è
zia il gioco dei problemi con la porta
arrivo su wii perdo che sei impaziente
di vedermi adesso arrivo sentirci passo
stessi ci parla chi cazzo blocca la
porta hai visto anche tu no perché non
numero sto spiegando sta roba
non so che cosa cazzo è successo però
porta a spasso un po di più il tuo
animaletto che lo vedo bel incazzato e
senza tempo magari vai anche un po dal
dentista
se avanza tempo e 26 molto belli
non apprezzi complimenti porca [ __ ] è
caduto mi spiaceva massima ma si muovono
i quadri mamma mamma
vedo di nuovo in 3d la mamma non ho
messo di nuovo gli utili ratatouille
sono proprio in casa ste merde certo la
cucina e dina ragazzi non so ma fate voi
si finito a posto è andato in cucina
ragazzi vanno a cucinarmi il polpettone
ciao zio ascoltami te i tuoi amici sono
andati in cucina se vuoi raggiungerli sì
sì no ma va benissimo il problema ma
perché cazzo parli ai topi l'uomo che
sussurrava ai topi ragazzi ognuno c'ha
le sue io parlo ai pupazzi
ecco parliamo anche le mosse a zona
allegati smorto sono a caso ma come
fanno dei topi a riceverne possibile
piazzo sono i topi di hulk si vede
ragazzi che niente si erano persi cucina
e succede succede di perdas in cucina
funziona così giorno la gemma una
piccata di muri prima o poi non so dire
se ti sei offerto volontario fallo tu
per me non frega un cazzo
grazie comunque lo apprezzo è una roba
che non ho capito chi sta spinge perché
c'è una tenda che tenuto a terra un
altro tocco alla ragazza c'è una tenda
che mi sta stuprata ciao la sedia e di
là la sedia quella che dalla vernice di
lato nella stanza di dietro se vuoi dare
una mano anche to die in vernice svezia
sono appena stato violentato da una
tenda di velluto se hai voglia di
rilassarmi un po in pace grazie proprio
e tutto questo già perché non ho capito
parliamoci chiaro avete intenzione di
farvi fare 55 metri senza che io muoia
oppure no tanto c'è del whisky prendiamo
è il sequel de l'uomo che sussurrava ai
topi e l'uomo che sussurrava al whisky
con dei topi della madonna che girano in
casa non mi stupisco che tu parli al
whisky zio trading
ok c'è una porta dentro un armadio che
cazzo siamo a narnia
quel giorno sono a narnia ragazzi che
bello altro che quattro a scuola tu hai
preso proprio due blindato la porta
manco fosse in punizione fratello credo
che sia chiusa ragazzi credo è un losco
ne sono sicuro che se la catena ma
questa è la stanza rossa quella di
mister grace dove scoprono così le
manette perché fa il trasgressivo bravo
ma avanti questo ragazzo e mister gray
che si è legato io lo sto torturando e
lui sta godendo di questi orgasmo vero
di uomo ragazzi ho aperto la porta tra
l'altro perfetto e stato orribile ci ho
dovuto torturare un uomo per aprire una
porta fantastico dato neanche visto chi
fosse ragazzi se mi fate c'è un
ascensore perfetto vai vai vai bene lei
veloce lotscher chiudi chiudi fisico
affetto grazie a dio ho trovato un
ascensore non ho idea di dove possa
portare ma [ __ ] tutto forte sega
ricerca quanto non peggiorato sto gioco
da ma mai lavato i capelli perché hai
rovesciato lo shampoo ed porca [ __ ]
ok se bloccato la scelta perfetta e il
momento preciso per far bloccare
l'ascensore che è l'allarme che è
scattato ragazzi
tra pochi alti porti cazzo merda no no
no no no se va bene ma [ __ ]
ma neanche se mi prega minchia che
brutto nove ragazzi è questa questa è
stata veramente pesante gas
fermi tutti geniale genia applausi a
caso non dovevo dire perché tipo il
cuore mi è finito in cucina però è un
altro discorso è la soffitta chiazzo
fianchi e tanto sogno che mi piano
infarti questo ragazzi vi insegna a non
togliere il pannolino ai bambini perché
si cagano addosso che che la metà basta
anche io però io c'ho vent'anni ed è
differente ma stai piangendo e vie viene
da qua al pianto è però non ho capito no
no quella non è mamma nomi the squad
grazie grazie
molto gentile me ne vado a [ __ ] anzi
ultima roba prima di andarmene guarda
tanti saluti cioè una roba devastante
rega non è possibile cos'è staro c'è un
quadro bello ciao quadro bello che bella
faccia nella pizza regale pizzaiolo che
ho chiamato ieri di nuovo la pizza ma
dovete le famiglie si sta suonando tel e
fax da squillando il libro
perché a su sto scrivendo un libro cioè
nascosto il telefono spero che tipo il
laboratorio di dexter non si apre alla
merda ha certo e mia madre che mi
nasconde il telefono solo perché prendi
4 manco bordin anna pizza un povero
cristiano perfetto pronta hai buttato a
terra delle cose 363 ama 3 site il
prefisso del mio kebabaro di fiducia
ragazzi chiamiamolo preside transita il
rischio credo che sia il numero del
kebabaro quindi chiamiamo il kebabbaro
ok pronto kebab a posto
nonni non funziona per chi kazzo dopato
macchia cazzo sta succedendo non vedevo
una roba del genere dai tempi di
hogwards e premesso semi fatti e salta
qualche chiudo e finito così se il serio
no non potete non vi ammazzo di schiaffi
giuro non possono far finire così un
gioco del genere non è possibile davvero
ragazzi è stata la risposta a tutto era
il kebabbaro la fine o chiamare il kebab
armi dispiace che sia durato così fuoco
perché mi chiama una figata pazzesca sta
roba però non quello che episodio è che
da quando sono tornato in casa mia e
l'atmosfera horror è ritornata ai vecchi
tempi
quindi ragazzi spero che vi do vi sia
piaciuto se anche a casa vostra i quadri
b consiglia nei kebab a rilasciate un mi
piace ha vinto perché lo so che lo fanno
con la sento sei video è piaciuta c'è
una quanto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come noi vidotto la tana
descrizione questi discreti noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video e le ragazze